about the fact that someone went out of
their way and they wanted to do a
wonderful gesture for you that's the
point and to sit here and demand an
eight carat ring so that someone next
door can see you across the road well
one year clearly you've got insecurities
because you feel like that's what's
going to add value to you because it's
not I'm interested because it's quite
interesting that upsets you
um because that's why I asked you well
I'm glad you clarified because at the
beginning you said you feel sorry for
her then you said you felt sorry for men
because
of the bad
I feel sorry for men because I mean
right
remember I said before we even watched I
knew what a woman looked like
and I think we can all categorically
agree without being a harsh that is a
bang average looking lady so that's the
problem